this is a particle robot alone it can't
do much just pulse out and back but as a
group these little BOTS can move towards
the light carry items even squeeze
through gaps and they can do those
things without any plan or central
coordination the useful behavior just
emerges from the way the group interacts
this is called stochastic mechanics and
it's the basis of many biological
systems think aunt Connie's or groups of
cells all these little robots can do is
change the regularity of their pulses in
response to light intensity add in some
loosely coupling magnets around the edge
and together the robots can push and
pull themselves along albeit slowly very
slowly the researchers say there are
some really distinct advantages to this
approach in theory robots that work in
this way could move through a whole host
of environments even places they've
never been before since they don't need
to assess plan or strategize they can be
flexible and essentially just muddle
through adapting in real time also like
a cluster of cells clusters of particle
robots don't need to be organized in a
particular structure or shape to work
they can just sort of move as an
amorphous blob the researchers modeled
their robots to see what might happen if
there were more safe a hundred or a
thousand of 10,000 and they found their
abilities scaled up along with the
number of BOTS
what's more they even disabled one in
five of them and the group prevailed all
this adds up to a robust system
something like you might find in biology
researchers say that in the future you
could put particle robots in any
environment mess up their order even
break a few and the system would still
work break a walking robots leg and
isn't going anywhere fast
because the output of the system relies
on complex interactions not complex
individuals each individual
but could be made even more simple while
still achieving high level tasks as a
group after that no central powerful
computer to coordinate the whole affair
an assistant seems a shoo-in for
miniaturization imagine swarms of
particle robot surgeons inside your body
but there's still work to do the
algorithms these particular BOTS use
might be tricky to translate into much
simpler or smaller robots but it is a
step or rather a pulsing shuffle in the
right direction
[Music]